acaso usted desestima el recurso
siguiendo la opinión de la magistrada
general la corte europea de justicia
desestimó la petición de varsovia y
budapest y aprobó el dispositivo que
liga el desembolso de fondos europeos al
respecto del estado de derecho en los
países del bloque polonia y hungría
reaccionaron en twitter hoy necesitamos
unidad frente a este ataque a nuestra
soberanía polonia tiene que defender su
democracia contra el chantaje que tiene
como objetivo privarnos de nuestro
derecho a la autodeterminación la cjv
emitió un juicio político es una prueba
viviente de que bruselas comete un abuso
de poder es un nuevo medio de presión
sobre nuestro país francia que asume
ahora la presidencia rotativa de la
unión europea celebró lo que calificó
como una buena noticia una opinión
replicada por su socio alemania el
estado de derecho es el fundamento de la
unión europea del recurso de la cj ue
representa un instrumento importante de
la unión europea cuyo papel es proteger
y reforzar nuestra comunidad de valores
el recurso dictado de este miércoles es
una victoria para bruselas en su combate
los dirigentes populistas de hungría y
polonia budapest es criticado por sus
violaciones a la independencia judicial
sus ataques a los derechos de la
comunidad lgbt y también por haber
cuestionado la primacía del derecho
europeo
varsovia por su lado ha sido
frecuentemente señalada por problemas
relacionados a la atribución de mercados
públicos o por casos de corrupción ahora
corresponde a la comisión europea
activar este instrumento que permite
privar a estos dos países de fondos
europeos